[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see uh what's
making the headlines with the associate
editor of the Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire
and the Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine
a very big welcome to both of you so
front pages let's start shall we with
the guardian there are claims on the
front page of the Guardian that
officials have raised concerns about the
conduct of the health secretary towards
civil servants the Department of Health
and Social care says it hasn't received
any formal complaints relating to its
ministers
The Daily Express carries the home
secretaries pledge to get more police
officers on on the ground more boots on
the ground as they put it the telegraph
says the architect of China's Crackdown
on pro-democracy protests in Hong Kong
is among the guests at the king's
coronation
that story also making the front page of
the Daily Mail
the Metro is covering a court case in
the US where a magazine writer is
accusing Donald Trump of an historic
sexual assault
the Ft reports on Microsoft's blocked
Bid to Buy video game maker Activision
Blizzard while the eye carries a warning
from doctors urging people not to buy a
popular weight loss drug online
and the Daily Star
has been investigating whether jaffa
cakes are really the best for dunking
and tea tonight they have the proof
still wrong remember a reminder that by
scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us our guests
so let's head straight to Kevin antacera
welcome to both of you a real mixed bag
of front pages there but let's kick off
with Sudan it feels like the story
that's happening now Kevin beginning to
get the testimony of those who've seen
dead bodies in the streets you know had
their cars stones and sticks and money
taken off them on the way to the airport
and still so many we know trying to get
out
I know that's right if 300 that was an
estimated 4 000 britons in Sudan of
course not all may want to leave but the
uh the papers uh sort of still go on the
front page including the Ft uh
complaints that the uh airport the the
strip being used is 40 kilometers north
of cartoon will set to about 25 miles uh
I know something to make the dash uh
risk in their lives but there we are a
picture of uh what looks like uh like a
family very very grateful to see uh
British Armed Forces personnel and uh
the government's been accused of being
slow Off the Mark uh the Ft points out
questions will be asked quite rightly
but um these operations are never easy
they're very very complex it's not just
as if the elite elite forces SES or
Marines or whatever can just go around
uh Cartoon other parts of Saddam picking
people up in cars and getting into the
airport just didn't work like that but
it must be terrifying for those who are
deciding really whether you gamble on
staying or leaving
yes just getting the latest figures
actually from the foreign Commonwealth
and development office the fcdo now
suggesting uh just in the last minute or
so that
536 uh people have been airlifted to
safety on six flights as the military
races against time obviously to rescue
these citizens we know we're in a
ceasefire we don't know what's going to
happen after the ceasefire we don't have
people are heading to Port Sudan on the
coasts era
um and the questions I suppose for the
British government will will rumble on
as they continue to try to get people
out
yes I mean they were quite slow off the
mark and
um they you know it didn't seem to be
well we didn't seem to be doing nearly
as well as the French uh who seem to get
their people out very quickly we got our
diplomats out didn't we but we we the
sort of civilians were sort of Trapped
behind I mean it seems to be catching up
now I mean it's very difficult to know
what's going on on the ground although I
have to say Sudan hasn't hasn't been a
particularly stable country for a while
so
um you know it'll it ought to have been
coming down the track for those
responsible
um let's just hope they get everyone out
as quickly as they can yes you're right
issues of South Sudan issues of Darfur
and uh no doubt we will get further
reports of the Sudanese people also
trying to flee Kevin just just quickly
on this
um The Who suggesting they're now going
to five neighboring countries so that's
kind of going to be the next phase once
Nations get their Nationals out
no that's right UK papers have been
focusing on UK and Nationals but we
mustn't forget the Sudanese civilians
they lost their democracy with a coup
two generals are now effectively
fighting over the spoils and what
happens next and the the Sudanese
themselves most of those dead if not all
will be will be Sudanese the 500 or so
when they they're going to neighboring
countries including Chad with reports
now that Chad's destabilized because of
the large numbers going over the Border
we often hear a lot in the UK concerns
raised about uh small boats and so on
over the channel but we have very very
few Asylum Seekers and refugees compared
to many other countries
let's move on then to the front page of
the Guardian Sarah after Dominic Raab
last week they bring you Steve Barkley
officials from the Department of Health
have raised concerns about the health
secretary Steve Barkley's alleged
conduct towards civil servants this is
they say a guardian exclusive
yes and they don't actually have any
there's no actual official Complaint yet
I think I mean I think that the Dominic
Robb thing
is bound to open the floodgates I think
there is an issue with uh we've
discussed this before I think there's
you know different sort of culture
different age groups you know older
ministers dealing with younger civil
servants and also the civil servants not
necessarily agreeing with the stuff that
the ministers are trying to do
um you know in America they have a
system whereby every time there's a
change of
um politics at the top you know all the
civil servants on one end go one side go
and then they get a whole new lot in who
are you know theoretically on on the
same page as as the new Administration
we don't have that we have an impartial
civil service or we're supposed to
um but you know it holds a lot of soft
power and you know this kind of thing is
a very good way of putting pressure on
the government
um and you know Rob went uh I think
sunak probably did the right thing
there were elements of the Rob report
that I think were a bit troubling and
also I I speaking to friends of mine who
are civil servants I know a few and I've
known a few over the years you know I
think they were you know what the there
wasn't there was some stuff going on
there that wasn't probably as we say
there was sub-optimal which is a
favorite Civil Service uh phrase
terminology for something that's
actually just not very good but uh I
don't know anything about Steve Barclay
I've never met him I'm sure you know who
knows I don't know if he's the thought
well I can only quote from the guardian
um we have not verified this ourselves
but they say uh source of sources have
told them that the civil servants had
informally complained to Chris wormald
the Department's permanent secretary
about the way they believed they and
colleagues had been treated they said
senior civil servants in the Department
of Health and Social care had privately
referred to bullying and other bad
behavior by Barclay towards his staff
since he joined the Whitehall Department
in July last year the alleged conduct is
denied by Barclays allies and I suppose
you might say
um that that department of all others
has seen extraordinary winter pressures
as we know and reported on all the time
but uh you know away from that um Kevin
this really has opened you know a debate
about whether you want that presidential
system like you get in America Clean
Sweep everybody out in they all come or
we cherish the independence of our civil
servants as part of the checks and
balances on our government
no no absolutely alone I think there is
a case for
uh secretaries of State I have more than
a couple of advisors to take in a small
um cabinet of political appointees in a
department you would still need a civil
service though below that and there
would be a connection between the two
and you can be a demanding Minister and
not be a bully or you can be a bully
who's a demanding Minister and across uh
I think all all parties you hear stories
about some people and I wasn't uh
entirely surprised about Dominic Robb
because quite frankly he was an arrogant
trap but I've not heard stories about uh
Steve Bartley that department has been
no that Department's been under
incredible pressure he will be under an
amazing amount of pressure because of
the strikes by nurses doctors uh
ambulance Crews and I do recall Pat
Cullen the General Secretary of the
Royal College of Nursing
um say she was um concerned about his
hostility at one meeting and I think
she's a mental health expert and she was
complaining about the aggressive way he
was uh he was sitting and uh and
behaving although it she didn't make any
accusation of of bullying so I'm sorry
I'm I'm slightly surprised but look we
can clear this one very quickly the
health select committee can call the
permanent secretary to give evidence on
oath and ask if those uh informal
complaints of of being made that we can
take it from there okay and also there's
a question about how you define bullying
isn't there I mean I think that's quite
an it's quite an important question what
is bullying you know is it is it just
being a bit short-tempered because
somebody hasn't done their job properly
or you don't think they've done their
job properly or is it targeting someone
and undermining them and making them
feel miserable and small that's what I
think bullying is so I think you know
there's a difference between a minister
who's who's short-tempered or who's
frustrated or tired or has got too much
on their plate and perhaps doesn't
doesn't operate politely or kindly
enough and and someone who is actively
bullying a member of Staff in order to
make it impossible to do that for them
to do their job so there is a question
yeah yeah you you're gonna have but you
can have bad behavior by ministers and
then you have bullying and Rob was found
uh to be vindictive uh unnecessarily
aggressive uh intimidating uh so I could
see why the uh the report by Adam uh
tolly uh KFC resulted in him having to
resign and he probably jumped before he
was pushed because I don't believe
sooner could have kept him or some
number 10 officials wanted to do to do
that but Barkley is going to require
um more investigation because the
allegations are there on the front of
the Guardian uh they can't just be
ignored now well one final paragraph I'm
going to read um the department said uh
the health department it had not
received any formal complaints over the
behavior of its ministers but did not
deny having been alerted to concerns
informally in the way sources described
so as you say we wait and watch and that
as they claim is an exclusive which as I
I say we have not verified ourselves
um onto the Metro Sarah another day
another court case um against
um the man who may be who knows the
Republican nominee for president
um next year
let me just can we just stop for one
second and just say I feel so sorry for
America having to choose between
Biden who is older than Methuselah and
uh Donald Trump who may or may not be in
jail by the time the election comes
around I mean it's just awful I mean
this is a this is a historic case um I
think it was 1996 it's supposed to have
happened she's a journalist she wrote
about it and then claims that he then
set about destroying her reputation it's
quite hard isn't it I don't know could
you could you prove with these historic
rape cases it's very difficult isn't it
to actually prove you know the rate
happened so it's just one person's word
against the other I mean I don't know
whether she has Witnesses or not but I
think you know quite
I don't think that you would necessarily
bring a civil case like this with all
the things that comes with that the
expense the stress the exhaust you know
the sort of exposure unless there unless
you really felt that you had to and she
she clearly does so we'll we'll have to
see how it unfolds but it's not the only
problem on that Trump is facing there
are still a lot of other things coming
down the track for him yeah I mean this
is in New York I think there's two other
ones in New York um obviously the one he
appeared in court for apart from a thing
uh one related to his business
activities as Georgia to come as well um
it's going to be an interesting summer
for him uh meanwhile let's go to the
Metro shall we
um and out goes Andrew bridgen uh
representative of Northwest
leicestershire after those comments he
made
um is it was it right again do you think
to to see him go Kevin
uh I think so uh I think he's completely
lost the lost the plot uh and he's you
know it's kind of quite uh sad in a way
just leaving a part of politics whether
you would agree them or not what other
mainstream issues is just somebody who
doesn't have any sense of reality I
believe uh now and complex
comparing in any way the vaccine program
with the Holocaust and however he did it
and he kind of denies it was quite like
that I think it was uh was a ludacy and
there were a lot of questions being
asked about him uh by by other MPS and
the Tory whips uh before this about
about his behavior and his views and so
so he's gone now I said that was a labor
seat he took it in 2010 for the concerts
and built up a huge majority so he's
going to stand as an independent I would
have thought some of the very small
right-wing parties uh that are nibbling
up the conservative party Lawrence Fox's
lot and so on there they may try and uh
try and get in but I think that's the
end of his political career now he'll
he'll lose up he'll lose out the
election if he stands as an independent
we saw that with all the conservatives
who were kicked out over
um brexit by Boris Johnson 2019 they
stood someone's independent some went
over to to change UK
others lib dams all lost not one of them
survived so it's uh bye bye bridges yeah
he has
a hand I just want to quote what he said
I have been a vocal critic of the
vaccine rollout and the party have been
sure to make an example of me and then
the article goes on to say that around
20 million lives were saved by the
covert vaccine in its first year
according to a search from Imperial
College London Sarah just very quickly
because I need to get uh I just think
he's gone down sort of conspiracy
theorist Rabbit Hole hasn't he and I I'm
a little bit worried that he's perhaps
not terribly well